et pour soir monsieur lamarre on sera
monsieur fillion 50 millions est ce que
c'est assez pour dire on assure notre
survie c'est pas suffisant pour dire ça
sur notre survie mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça va nous
permettre de passer à travers un
processus de recapitalisation et ça ça
devrait dans ce deuxième temps là nous
permettre de dire à l'ensemble de nos
employés que le cirque du soleil va
survivre donc où je vous parle je suis
extrêmement confiant pour ne pas dire
assuré que le cirque du soleil sera
encore là l'an prochain
prêt pour ouvrir son spectacle pour une
première mondiale dans ie pas à la même
date l'an prochain est ce que
l'entreprise pourrait tout de même se
placer sous la protection des tribunaux
c'est clairement un scénario qui est
envisagé il ya plusieurs scénarios qui
sont envisagées on travaille beaucoup
présentement avec nos actionnaires et on
travaille également en collaboration
avec les sources d'investissements des
gouvernements et j'aimerais préciser
d'ailleurs qu'on ne parle pas de
subvention ici on parle vraiment
d'investissement qui permettra au
gouvernement en s'impliquant dans voir
un retour intéressant lorsqu'on va
reprendre nos activités
on parle du gouvernement du québec fait
principalement on parle d'investissement
québec
évidemment la pierre angulaire de toute
séduction lancée la caisse de dépôt le
ministre fixe been joue un rôle
important
on est chanceux d'avoir un ministre qui
connaît bien le milieu des affaires qui
a déjà vécu des restructurations donc on
pense avoir un partenaire de choix pour
réussir l'opération
donc ce serait une opération avec la
caisse de dépôt avec investissement
québec pourquoi pour racheter le cirque
du soleil
c'est un scénario qui est effectivement
envisagé comme je voulais dire plusieurs
scénarios envisagés au moment où je vous
parle et au cours des prochaines
semaines
on aura un tracé qui sera beaucoup plus
claire pour l'ensemble de la population
et j'espère
pidement pouvoir être capable de
rassurer nos employés qui sont
malheureusement chez eux pour moment où
je vous parle pour les rappeler pour les
réembaucher
absolument c'est le scénario que l'on
regarde évidemment ça peut être plus
long que je l'aurais espéré
parce que je pense que le virus fait des
dommages plus importants mais les règles
un peu partout à travers le monde où
vont nous obliger à des délais
additionnels
mais lorsque l'on reviendra une certaine
normalité son espère s'y plaint mais à
ce moment là on va reprendre aux
activités donc si je ré ouvre un
spectacle dans un moment et peut-être
dans certains cas avant parce que la
chine
on parle déjà d ouvrir prochainement
mais à ce moment là on va rappeler
graduellement nos employés pierre karl
péladeau le pdg de quebecor était à rdi
économie lundi soir voici ce qu'il a dit
à propos du cirque du soleil on sait que
le cirque en grande partie doit son
succès à ceux qui le font de façon
quotidienne aux artistes aux
collaborateurs et c'est important
justement de faire en sorte que cette
pérennisation exister si la raison pour
laquelle nous avons fait connaître notre
intérêt nous ont fait connaître leur
intérêt est également aussi de procurer
un financement à court terme
que pensez-vous de l'intention de
quebecor d'abord je suis très d'accord
avec l'affirmation qu'il vient de faire
il a raison la pérennité surpassant nos
créateurs aux artistes nos employés
je dois dire que je suis très flatté de
l'intérêt de québec a qui quand même une
grande entreprise
je dois vous dire qu'il y a aussi
d'autres grandes entreprises qui ont
démontré de l'intérêt
hier d'autres grands investisseurs qui
ont démontré de l'intérêt
les sponsors tout à l'heure j'étais
aussi affirmatif aux ir que l'avenir du
soleil était assurée parce que cette
grande marque mondiale là mais si
aujourd'hui ne génère pas de revenus
tout le monde en comprend et encornets
la potence
elle alors avoir des gens qui s'y
intéressent mais encore une fois dans
toute l'opération de restructuration
dont on part ça nous offre encore plus
d'options et ça ça devrait être
rassurant pour nos employés
est ce qu'il y à des négociations avec
quebecor non mais encore une fois il
rend processus qui sera mise en en place
au cours des prochaines semaines et on
va écouter ce que les gens ont à nous
dire quand on parle d'un exercice de
récapitulation ce qui est important de
comprendre par là c'est que aujourd'hui
nos actionnaires actuels ont envoyé un
signal très fort parce que eux ne
veulent pas se départir de l'entreprise
ne veut ne pas se départir de ce grand
show you alors pour l'instant c'est eux
qui sont au premier plan aux premières
loges
par la suite ils verront ils décideront
s'ils ont besoin de partenaires ou pas
est ce que quebecor peut avoir accès à
vos chiffres le jour où ils signeront
une entente de confidentialité sont une
fois grand plaisir de discuter avec eux
tout comme le font présentement d'autres
grands groupes qui eux sont intéressés à
entamer également des discussions
est ce que d'autres grands groupes ont
accès à vos livres en ce moment ça se
fera au cours des prochains jours oui
mais je peux vous et au moment où je
vous parle qui lie à des groupes qui ont
signé des ententes de confidentialité
est ce que guy laliberté a démontré un
intérêt de redevenir actionnaire non on
n'a pas eu comme vous le savez s'est
départi de 10% qui lui restait quelques
semaines à peine avant cette crise là
alors personnellement je n'ai pas
entendu parler de qui au cours des cours
des dernières des dernières semaines le
fer du soleil
retour à la normale c'est pour quand
selon vous selon votre projection
écoutez je suis pas un scientifique mais
lorsque j'écoute les gens en pensent que
dans un an il y aura eu un vaccin de
découvert et ou en médicaments et le
jour où les gens ne se sentiront plus
menacés pour leur santé je pense qu'ils
vont accourir
les spectacles parce que les gens
souffrent beaucoup présentement dans le
confinement les gens très d'aller dans
les restaurants dans les hôtels et
d'aller dans les théâtres
donc nous on pense que dès qu'il y aura
normalité on va avoir une vente de
billets probablement un record et
notamment ici à montréal dans une loi
mais vous donc vous vous donnez c'est ça
que vous vous donnez vous donner une
bonne année devant vous avant de revenir
à la normale monsieur fignon c'est très
important ce que vous venez de dire on
regarde ça avec un plan d'affaires très
réaliste et c'est important d'être très
conservateur parce qu'il ya trop d 6
d'incertitude dans le marché et on ne va
pas ouvrir nos spectacles de façon
prématurée
on va ouvrir nos spectacles lorsqu on
sentira que les gens se sentent en
sécurité
merci beaucoup daniel lamarre et bonne
chance merci au revoir